RUSSIA FOR DARING TO DO THAT,
THEY DID NOT CHARGE HER FOR THE
CRIME, SO SHE IS FREE TO JOIN US
TONIGHT, DR. JILL STEIN,
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
DO YOU THINK THE PARTY OF
DIVERSITY WOULD BE FOR MORE
DIVERSE ABUSE, BUT THEY ARE NOT,
WHY IS THAT?
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT IT IS A
PARTY OF DIVERSITY, WE HAVE TWO
PARTIES THAT ARE WORKING FOR
CORPORATE MASTERS AND THE FOSSIL
FUEL GIANTS IN THE BIG BANKS,
WALL STREET, AND THE WAR
MACHINE.
THAT IS NOT MY OPINION THAT TO
THE DEMOCRATS IS THE PARTY OF
DIVERSITY, BUT FORD      VOTERSD
DIVERSITY, BUT FORD      VOTERSS
DIVERSITY, BUT FORD      VOTERSR
DIVERSITY, BUT FORD      VOTERSE
MORE CHOICES.
IN THE LAST ELECTION WE SAW OVER
100 MILLION VOTERS, THE LARGEST
BLOC OF VOTERS IS NOT TO VOTING,
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT BEING
REPRESENTED BY THE SYSTEM.
WE NEED NONCORPORATE CHOICES AND
PEOPLE POWER CHOICES.
AND WE CAN HAVE THOSE CHOICES
WITHOUT FEAR OF SPLITTING VOTES.
THERE IS A WIN-WIN SOLUTION.
IT IS CALLED RANKED CHOICE
VOTING.
THE STATE OF MAINE JUST PASSED
IT.
IT IS USED BY MILLIONS OF VOTERS
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
SO IT REALLY MAKES OBSOLETE THIS
WHOLE ISSUE OF THE STRUGGLE
BETWEEN WELCOME WE HAVE CHOICES?
OR DO WE HAVE TO FORCE PEOPLE
INTO TWO PIGEONHOLES THAT THE
MAJORITY OF VOTERS, ALMOST 60%
OF VOTERS ARE SAYING THAT WE
NEED A NEW INDEPENDENT POLITICAL
PARTY, BECAUSE THEY ARE TIRED OF
BEING THROWN UNDER THE BUS BY
THE OTHER TWO.
WHETHER WE HAVE DEMOCRATS OR
REPUBLICANS.
IT IS NOT WORKING OUT SO WELL
FOR EVERYDAY WORKING PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT IS
PROBABLY RIGHT.
>> WE NEED MORE CHOICES, AND WE
CAN HAVE IT.
SO LET'S NOT KEEP THAT A SECRET.
WE SHOULD REQUIRE THESE ELECTED
TO ACTUALLY PASS A SIMPLE
REFORM, THE STATE OF MAINE JUST
STAYED IN IT.
IT IS AVAILABLE TO US RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: I WONDER --
>> BEFORE THE 2020 ELECTION
PRETTY >> Tucker: I FOLLOW
THAT CLOSELY, BECAUSE I AM
INTERESTED IN MAINE, I'M NOT
SURE THAT I UNDERSTAND
RANKED-CHOICE VOTING FOR THE
PEOPLE I MAY NOT UNDERSTAND IT.
>> THEY THINK THAT THEY DO.
>> I MAY BE THEY DO MAYBE I
WOULD IF I STUDIED HARDER.
>> I CAN EXPLAIN IT TO YOUR
REALLY QUICK.
>> Tucker: YOU COULD NOT,
TRUST ME, I HAVE TRIED.
HERE'S A BROADER QUESTION, WHY
DOES THE MEDIA COOPERATES WITH
THIS EFFORT TO SHUT DOWN ANYBODY
WHO OFFERS AN ACTUAL TO
WHAT WE HAVE? IT OPEN MINDED
ENOUGH TO LET THE CANDIDATES
SPEAK OF THEIR PIECE, DO THEY
HAVE TO CRUSH PEOPLE, ACCUSE
THEM OF BEING RUSSIAN AGENTS IF
THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT VIEW?
>> IF THEY WERE DOING THEIR JOB,
THEIR JOB IS TO EDUCATE VOTERS,
NOT TO TELL VOTERS OR TO
PIGEONHOLE VOTERS OR TO VILIFY
VOTERS FOR EXPRESSING THEIR
DISCONTENT WITH TWO PARTIES THAT
HAVE THROWN THEM UNDER THE BUS.
IN THE LAST ELECTION WE HAD TWO
CANDIDATES WHO ARE THE MOST
DISLIKED AN UNTRUSTED IN MODERN
HISTORY, AND 75% OF VOTERS WERE
SCREAMING FOR OPEN DEBATES.
THEY WANTED TO HEAR FROM THE
LIBERTARIAN AND THE GRAIN.
THEY WANTED TO HEAR FROM A
DEBATE ABOUT OUR WAR MACHINE.
WHICH IS GOING FULL SPEED AHEAD,
AND THE LAST TAX DAY, THE
AVERAGE TAXPAYER PAID OVER
$3500, PRACTICALLY TO THE WAR
MACHINE, AND $40 TO THE EPA TO
GIVE US CLEAN AIR AND WATER.
HOW'S THAT WORKING OUT FOR US?
NOT SO WELL.
>> Tucker: EVERYTHING NEEDS TO
BE DEBATED.
THAT IS A PLACE WHERE WE AGREE
VEHEMENTLY, ARE YOU GOING TO RUN
AGAIN IN 2020, DO YOU THINK?
>> I DO NOT HAVE ANY PLANS TO
RUN AT THIS POINT.
THERE IS PLENTY TO DO.
AND I FEEL LIKE I'VE DONE MY
DUTY THIS TIME AROUND.
AND IT IS TIME FOR SOMEONE ELSE
TO CARRY THAT BANNER, BUT I AM
CERTAINLY FIGHTING FOR THE CAUSE
OF MORE VOICE IS MORE CHOICES ON